is for you pleasure to drink pity to see
her
we can remove these this can be well
this is her height controller for short
later like this and tolerable what
specific message do you think is the
most important climate change is coming
much much faster
mm-hmm we have seen such an
extraordinarily extreme weather patterns
if you consider this a vastness of this
universe this aprendido is just a small
boat if this boat is sinking that I
think we will have to all sing together
I know that he has been a very committed
and effective environmentalist and that
is why I will count on your leadership
and vision
Thank You mr. secretary-general your
excellency I feel incredibly honored
that they chose me to be the United
Nations messenger piece on climate
change not as an expert I want to do
everything I can to learn more about
this issue see for myself exactly what's
going on and what can be done but it all
kind of seems beyond our control as an
actor
I pretend for a living I play fictitious
characters often solving fictitious
problems
I believe that mankind has looked at
climate change in that same way we keep
getting inundated with catastrophic news
about the environment every single day
and the problem seems to be getting
worse and worse and worse
try to have a conversation with anyone
about climate change people just to now
if the UN really knew how I feel
how messy mystic I am about our future I
mean to be honest they may have picked
the wrong guy